Flo Rida's six-year-old son hospitalized
after falling out of an apartment Window
he suffered a shattered pelvis fractures
uh problems with his liver internal
bleeding and collapsed lungs so uh he is
alive thank God thank you God the
rapper's son named Zohar P Dillard fell
from a fifth floor window of his of his
mom's New Jersey apartment comp
into multiple reports his mother Alexis
Adams filed a lawsuit against her
building's management company over the
March 4th incident citing negligence
Alexis and Zohar are named as plaintiffs
in a case against Pitch Perfect 74 LLC
Goldberg management Carlos Machado and
multiple unnamed building and
construction companies submitted to the
superior court of New Jersey on March
27th in the legal filings Alexis's
attorney alleges that management
installed incorrect sized guards on the
Windows even though these windows were
on a fifth floor story apartment thereby
breaching their duty of care Alexis's
legal team is calling for a jury trial
claiming the managers are at fault for
maintaining the building in a negligent
careless and Reckless manner creating
foreseeable and dangerous conditions the
lawsuit is asking for an undisclosed
amount of Damages for zohar's current
and future medical bills legal fees and
any ongoing and future physical and
mental pain and suffering in a statement
to News 12 New Jersey Alexis explains as
a single mom to a special needs child
this feels like a nightmare she adds
that her heart is broken into a million
pieces I am devastated angry and
struggling to come to terms with the
fact that my only child has suffered
severe injuries due to willful negative
agents of our landlord and others
involved in failing to take necessary
safety measures
ET has reached out to Reps for Flo Rida
and Alexis for comment
foreign